[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein ganz schnelles rezept
ich werde ich nämlich in workshops
machen ingo shops sind gerade momentan
wirklich super wichtig denn sie stärkt
ihre abwehrkräfte und das immunsystem
gibt es bei uns aber tatsächlich immer
wir machen auch morgens gerne smoothies
wir machen gerne vitaminreiche sachen
und wir essen auch viel gemüse und obst
denn ein gesundes abwehrsystem und gute
kräfte sind wirklich super wichtig er
hilft mir jetzt auch gleich mit ich
werde irgendwie schaut machen mit ingwer
mandarinen zitronen und kurkuma und
warum solltet ihr im wasser trinken und
keine ingwertee vielleicht dazu kurz war
es irgendwas werden roh zubereitet das
heißt da irgendwo wird nicht erhöht die
zitrone wird nicht erhitzt und wenn ihr
etwas trinkt lässt zwar auch gut aber
ich hab einfach viel mehr vitamine und
mineralstoffe
wenn ihr die sache ist also bitte auch
bei anderen rezepten darauf achten
einfach nicht erhitzen sondern wirklich
vor trinken unseren kleiner schott am
tag so ein kleines geld sind am tag
reicht auch wirklich vollkommen aus die
kinder trinken sie übrigens auch mit
ich nehme drei bis vier anderen ich habe
große daher nehme ich jetzt 3 ich habe
hier 200 gramm ingwer und ich hab sogar
noch ein stück kurkuma dabei ich habe
ich vier zitronen etwas kurkuma als
pulver und 400 gramm wasser was sie
jetzt auch dafür braucht ist ein mixer
ihr können stabmixer nehmen und
hochleistungs mixa ihr könnt aber auch
eine reibe nehmen und alles zerkleinern
natürlich schmeckt im ganzen besser wenn
alles schön cremig und fein püriert ist
an sonst hat man beim irgendwann einfach
diese fasern die manche vielleicht sogar
störend empfinden aber es ist nur ein
kleiner short also ich habe das auch
schon in anderen mixa zubereitet denn
nicht alle so toll zerkleinert und es
geht
ich nehme die mandarinen da nehme ich
den saft da mandarinen einfach etwas
süßer sind die bringen die süße mit rein
ihr könnt gerne auch mit honig nach
süßen aber da ging es eigentlich nur was
wenn ihr imker honig vom imker vor ort
nimmt weil da einfach die ganze anfangs
stoffe drin habt die eben für euch in
eurer region dann gut sind
ich lasse sitz weg damit eben auch vegan
ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und meine mixa einfach darauf achten die
weichen in sachen die weichen
lebensmittel unten rein und die härteren
obendrauf als irgendwann dann obendrauf
damit sich die messe einfach nicht
behagen
[Musik]
hier noch schön den rest saft ausdrücken
ok dann nehme ich hier denn ingwer ich
habe immer bio irgendwo das heißt ich
kann auch die schale mit verwenden
das einzige was ich mache ist hier diese
harten stelle im löffel einfach
wegzunehmen und da würde ich auch eltern
zu bio ingwer greifen denn ihr könnt die
schale mit verwenden und dann lohnt sich
das auch mit den kosten dann habe ein
paar weniger abfall weniger verschnitt
und irgendwie enthält einfach viel
kalium phosphor und vitamin c
und die sind wirklich zur stärkung der
abwehrkräfte notwendig also daher
solltet ihr auch wirklich regelmäßig
irgendwo verzehren super gesund
ich werde gleich nur in grobe stücke
schneiden und außerdem weg das darin
enthaltene ginger roll schmerzlindernd
entzündungshemmend und schleimlösend
also hat man wirklich viele viele
vorteile
ich streite das hier einfach nur gut
wenn ihr nicht so starken mixa dann
etwas kleiner schneiden
außerdem ist rhizom enthalten und das
wirkt antibakteriell und kann auch zu
einer gesunden darmflora beitragen
außerdem hemmt die vermehrung von viren
und ich weiß noch ich hatte eine zeit
lang über magenbeschwerden und irgendwas
auch ganz gut gegen abbrechen das heißt
wenn ihr marke probleme habt könnt ihr
das auch ganz gut nehmen
aber was er unbedingt beachten müsst
wenn ihr schwanger sein sollte nicht so
viel irgendwann verzehren da irgendwo
wehen fördert ist also da wusste ich
auch muss sich gegen ende der
schwangerschaft auf ingwer verzichten
ja ich hab ich noch kurkuma kurkuma ist
eine richtig schöne orangene wurzel die
gibt es oftmals auch im supermarkt aber
wenn er koma frisch nicht bekommt nehmt
ihr einfach getrocknetes kurkuma pulver
seht ihr das anders aus wirkt aber auch
super und das bekommt jetzt hier auch
rein
die zitronen sind auch bio da werde ich
jetzt die schale abnehmen
die könnt ihr jetzt nehmen und dann zum
beispiel zum backen weiter verwenden
also den gelben teil und den weißen teil
schneidig weg hat er nämlich eigentlich
mit bitter schmeckt
[Musik]
und jetzt gebt ihr hier noch wasser dazu
und püriert alle auf höchster stufe
[Musik]
ich hab ich jetzt hier mit der smoothie
stufe gemacht denn beim mixen müsst ihr
aufpassen wenn ihr einen hochleistungs
mixa habt der erwerb die zutaten durch
die reibung und die mutti stufe die
bleibt immer unter einer gewissen grad
zahl und dann erwärmt sich nichts
[Musik]
und für die kinder nehme ich einfach für
sie den apfelsaft naturtrüben das kommt
dann hier rein
die mögen den geschmack nämlich nicht so
gerne ein bisschen verstecken
also für ella und moral was haben wir da
weiß das ist gesund ist okay jetzt dürft
ihr kommen euren täglichen irgendwo
short abholen
hier forscht
prof
und austrinken austrinken
und mit wasser ausspülen noch mal
trinken rauschtrinken wolga nächster
rutscht verträge mit wasser nachspülen
vegan
ja ja morgen zum affen und vegan marcel
trick hinter der kamera
der möchte ich mich zeigen new york der
letzte stand für dich okay ja nichts
süßes recht kein honig um so reich und
so der leitstelle
ich mag seine art ausgetrunken sehr gut
und gott machen jetzt weitermacht waren
wärmen von innen also macht auf jeden
fall nach vor wut aus und bleibt gesund
[Musik]